hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines in which today there's a number
of things I want to do again
first and foremost I wanted to add a
couple of farms over here which has no
real reason to it other than that I just
felt like doing it but I also want to
redo much of the foliage throughout the
city since as you can see I removed all
of the autumn trees and I like it more
myself whether you like it or not is up
to opinion I suppose but I just feel
it's much more realistic and I couldn't
really get the autumn thing to work too
well so this in the end should make
things look a little bit more realistic
I think but it does mean that since I
removed all of the autumn trees I have
to add a couple extra trees and rework
the foliage a bit so that's something
that I wanted to do as well also wanted
to start working but not really finish
it yet on a park in the middle of the
city where I not only have some trees
and some open areas where you can just
walk around and chill and stuff like
that but also a swimming pool and leave
some areas open for later on some small
basketball tennis courts or things like
that basically a small sort of central
park where people can just relax and
also and this is probably the biggest
thing of the episode I want to
completely redo one of the oldest parts
of this city as much as last time that I
actually announced that I would redo
parts of the city we sort of met with
reactions of no yishun I think I
definitely wanted to redo this part of
the city it's just about almost the
oldest part with well you'll see it
eventually but I'm redoing some parts of
the city I won't redo everything
definitely not but I want to change one
of the older areas which is very 70s at
the moments - more 90s
Zero's style housing just because I feel
like it fits more into the general area
where I now added many of these modern
modern houses but also just because I
didn't like the layouts it was before
and for others not 70s and earlier
neighborhoods that I wanted redo i do
want to restore them to for example call
the flower neighborhoods but just a bit
better than they are right now but
that's for fun in the future anyway
something i wanted to talk about while
we're still on the subject of farms over
here is that i wanted to thank everybody
who left comments about the
entire forum system in the Netherlands
because in general I was really just
trying to imitate the way that farms
look but I didn't really have a good
understanding of why exactly the way
they are the way they are and actually
got many comments about that and I'm
sorry I couldn't be applied to all of
them but I have read all of the comments
and there's actually some handy stuff to
know in there especially the fact that
these fields also stretched out because
it's just more practical with having to
turn around with your farming equipment
but also it's very good to know actually
that these are some of the other fields
as opposed to well clearly some of the
fields like in the baby store which are
much larger and also more recently
Pollard but a very good example it'd be
flavor lunch which is the newest
province in the Netherlands which has a
very great like and widely set up farm
fields with enormous farms as well but
in this case I definitely want to go
with the more older type farms and in
general the type of farm that you would
find around the area where I live is
what I'm going to sort of make in this
case and that also in a way does bring
me to talk about the way that this
entire city is planned a little bit
because there's the general idea of the
city it's actually not a city which sort
of grows over time and so it doesn't
really have the standard layout that you
would find with many city with many
cities whether it's the very old core
and they get a 19th century ring around
that and then the 20th century early
20th century and also the post Second
World War flat neighborhoods and simple
row houses with their red roofs and
stuff and it doesn't really follow this
type of well timeline really but rather
I this would be a city which is selected
as a place of Urban development's which
is commonly done in the Netherlands to
prevent cities from growing too much and
to make sure that green areas stay green
so instead they sort of leave the green
areas to be not so much developed
anymore and a point one city where lots
and lots of houses are newly built as a
sort of suburb thing and that's the
general idea of this city it's very
similar I feel in a way too
how Hollywood slows is which also has
the star Ford Center and some of the
more newly developed assigned houses
around it and so that's the general idea
of the city and that's also why it
doesn't really follow that entire
onion-like metaphor of older Center and
then you kind of go newer as you go more
to the outer sections of the city but
rather it's going to be just an old
Center with only newer stuff around it
and that's the general idea for this
city
so yeah just something to keep in mind I
suppose when it comes to how this
planning of the city might not be very
representative of all the cities in the
Netherlands I just felt like this was a
fun type of city to work on um though
that said I do still want to redo these
cauliflower neighborhoods over here and
the one with the large roundabouts since
I just don't feel like they're too
realistic but I may very well replace
this cauliflower neighbourhood with
another cauliflower neighbourhood in a
way that O'Meara also started off with
cauliflower neighborhoods as the oldest
parts but at least I want to redo them
even though I sort of redid them with
the foliage over here I'm not even
talking about when I'm doing Wow and
this is also where I had a couple of
houses cut off from the rest of the map
which was pretty stupid but that was why
it was burning and stuff people did
comment on that saying I'm sure you
noticed that and yeah I sort of did it
was painful though and I still don't
understand how I didn't notice it at
first anyway this is the area oh never
mind that'll be in a second I don't even
know how I forgot that because this is
the second time I'm recording this
anyway I wanted to do the park right
here and a lot of inspiration and I must
say it's almost stolen from the park in
a town called Henry Thomas where they've
also got these oval paths you do find it
I'm here and they're quite often but
it's it's a type of layout for the park
I figured it's very nice since I could
make the middle of this park
quite open for people to just sit down
or have a game of Frisbee and someone
commented but um also make sure that the
sides to have some trees and that I do
get a good amount of forest in there as
well
and the idea is at the moment to leave
that top right corner open to maybe have
a skate park or basketball court over
there and then all the way the rights
between this park and the river is where
I want to have the swimming pool but
you'll see that in a bit I do have to
say about this park there was quite a
lengthy recording of this and doing all
the foliage which was very much fun but
um yeah that's where fraps stopped
recording because my hard drive was
completely filled and I didn't notice
that so sorry about that that's all gone
but by now the entire park is filled
with foliage so that should be fine now
about the topic of swimming pools I
actually see many swimming pools in my
life since I play water polo and I've
seen like all these swimming pools in
the regions in the region just about
here and it was kind of hard to find the
exact assets that I wanted to and I
still don't feel like this is too
representative of a typical Dutch
swimming pool usually it's a bit of a
larger complex where most of it is
indoor since the Netherlands just
doesn't have that great of a climate so
you don't want to have too many of your
pools outdoors and that usually builds
by on the city and sort of planned and
every single every single city in the
Netherlands seems to have the exact same
swimming pool just with it slightly
different layouts and there's some water
slides and saunas and stuff like that
but I couldn't really get that in here
so the closest thing that I did find was
a club over here and I wanted to at
least add some decorations to it that
would make it look a little bit more
Dutch but yeah this was about the
closest thing I could find it was also a
aqua park with a weird waterslide but
some of the other assets either were too
large or too small or the water color
was very weird and this just was the
best-looking one I think and so yeah I
just wanted to get some assets in there
and some props to make sure that it
looks a little bit more Dutch so there's
the parking lot in front of it and loads
of stuff around the small field of grass
over here with the playground and some
picnic tables and some chairs where you
can lie down and stuff like that and
that's the general idea but it's a
pretty small swimming pool and it
doesn't have as much as you would
typically find
in the Netherlands I might replace it at
some point in time if ever
somebody releases a new type of swimming
pool in the workshop that works a bit
better than this one this is what I want
to stay with for now and this is
actually finally where I wanted to build
or at least rebuild in this neighborhood
and the reason why I sort of wanted to
do it over here is because this is more
toward the edge of the city so even
though the city is generally a planned
city you still of course find that the
older neighborhoods are located more
towards the edges and since this
neighborhood was already so close to all
the other newer neighborhoods that I
added and since I wasn't happy about the
previous layouts I just figured whatever
I'm gonna completely redo this entire
thing and a special shout out I have to
say goes to voters for this thing since
he actually went through the work of why
I didn't specially do it for me but he
actually sent me a Google Docs that he
made a folder with all sorts of photos
of dueting home which included some of
the newer vinick's neighborhoods of
tooting home and a bit of inspiration
from that is actually in here especially
in the half circle over here which you
can find in many different neighborhoods
in many Phoenix neighborhoods in the
Netherlands but I sort of followed these
same formats with the types of houses
and especially with the slanted roof
houses on the outside and having these
detached houses in half a circle and
then the row houses in the straight
roads around it and another point of
pretty good inspiration was actually to
sort of limit the road layout so that
cars can't really easily get everywhere
but make sure that you have these
bicycle shortcuts and pedestrian
shortcuts everywhere and on the topic of
that is something that I should probably
mention as well if I haven't explicitly
stated this before I am planning around
all of my bicycle paths at the moment so
for instance these paths over here not
sort of cut through in the neighborhood
to make sure that you can get from A to
B without having to follow the annoying
road pattern are planned to be bicycle
paths and the same goes for the
pedestrian paths that currently fall
roads or sort of cut through rural
landscapes to go from one time to
another but at the moment they're just
not bicycle paths because I'm a lazy bum
and I don't have after dark yet so I
don't really have access to it yet but
once I do and once the city might
actually work because I'm not sure if
it's actually going to work on after
dark and stay to actually be functional
city
I will definitely update all of the
pedestrian paths that are sort of
currently planned as bicycle paths to
actual bicycle paths but that's
something that should come and do time
but yeah you can actually find quite a
lot I think of this neighborhood in the
general Phoenix neighborhoods in the
Netherlands and I'm really happy about
it I think this is my favorite
neighborhood so far and definitely quite
similar to what you'd find in real life
but I it was still quite a lot of fun to
mess around with it only thing that
wasn't so much fun and you're going to
see more of this and this is going to be
quite time-consuming from this point
onward is that I have to select every
single house and make sure that they
don't level up to make sure that the
houses stay the same and of course add
all the hatches to it but yeah that's
not too bad it's it's I do still like
the end product and it's something that
I should randomly mention or at least do
things that I kinda want to talk about
in a sort of portico style one just to
learn a new background is first and
foremost when it comes to the general
city there are many suggestions of
things that I should do and things that
I really want to do as well that are
sort of not really realistic for a city
this size and I'm referring to things
like an airport or a theme park and
those are definitely things that I wanna
at least at some point in the future
make but are just not realistic to get
in and I have to say it when it comes to
things like these I'm just gonna
sacrifice realism just to have fun and
mess with different aspects of things
that you'd see in the Netherlands
because I'm not just trying to make a
Dutch region but also trying to get many
of the typical Dutch things out there
and of course just have fun and I
definitely wanna mess around with an
airport and when it comes to the theme
park that is very much something I
wanted
so I will sacrifice a bit of realism to
get some things in that you wouldn't
normally see for a city like that and
I'll be getting to some of the
preposterous recommendations I suppose
though I'm not sure if I really want to
take everything and of course most
limited to just 81 titles which proved
to not be as much as I initially hoped
but yeah that's gonna be a lot of fun in
the future and also some of that I might
want to talk about is I've actually had
some common discussions about Holland
Ferdinand versus the Netherlands and I
sort of just snare that everyone who is
making comments about Holland or the
Netherlands which I kind of feel bad
about because I used to just use them
interchangeably both terms
but that's something which is not really
correct since the Netherlands is very
much a different thing from Holland and
for those of you who don't know Holland
happens to be two provinces of the
country the Netherlands but Holland is
not actually a country and I refer to
the country as Holland but that was
really just because it's easier to say
but quite frankly to this city is
actually placed in the province of
Holland and that sort of complicates
things as well since it really isn't
representative of the rest of the
Netherlands anyway I want to hurry up a
bit just for the real-time part which I
planned in here um in the end I'll just
say the Netherlands from now on anyway
it's on the real time all right so
here's the current state of things and I
kind of like it really especially the
different mix of different houses it's
very reminiscent of late 90s or even
later housing style and I think actually
this combined with this entire area
pretty much with all these similar
houses is by far my favorite part of the
city so far and what I think most
closely resembles what real modern
vinick's neighbourhoods are like so I
think I really think that I just want to
remove this part since it's so 70s 80s
and it might just be more realistic to
call this entire thing a 90s thing
although I would say this is a little
other than in this point it still is
reasonably the same age in general and I
just kind of like this time a little bit
more than what I have over here so I
might just remove this over time and do
more stuff with this I mean like these
Swedish houses really sort of proved
themselves that you can tell that they
aren't entirely Dutch but these houses
it kind of like them so far they've even
got a very Dutch aged brick texture to
it
and you actually very commonly see
houses with roofs like this in very new
Dutch neighborhoods and they're more
widely and spaced out than the older
neighborhoods are which you kind of see
in here as well like all of them have
somewhat large gardens and there's more
detached houses than row houses which is
a sort of style that I would like to
keep in the rest of the city just a
little bit more so probably I'm gonna
want to do a similar style over here and
I might branch off over here and add
some outer part of the city over here as
well as somewhere here though I'm not
entirely sure what I'm gonna do with
this like I'm probably gonna put Stadium
here University here and see what I'll
do with the rest and this part of the
city which is still kind of hard to do
stuff with but yeah that's it for this
episode next episode I have no [ __ ]
clue what I'm gonna do
but thanks for watching oh and also a
small side note that I forgot to say
when I was recording this commentary and
my fields are too big and I will fix
that in the future I'll definitely make
them quite a bit larger by removing some
of the pedestrian paths
[Music]